alors quand vous êtes maire de levallois
vous vous transformez que cette banlieue
populaire en une espèce de nuit c'est
pas une espèce de neuilly c'est une
ville où il ya cinquante cinq mille
habitants et 50000 emplois parce que
quand je suis arrivé dans la ville il y
avait que des usines qui était en train
de péricliter il y avait les usines de
deux chevaux citroën qui était en train
de fermer
et pour l'économie de la ville il a
fallu faire venir des entreprises se
battre avec les pouvoirs publics pour
construire des des bureaux des logements
des équipements tout genre et je les
fais pendant 12 ans et je crois que les
levalloisiens on était très heureux de
toute cette transformation à preuve
c'est qu'ils viennent de vous relire
donc voilà bon hein vous créer une
police municipale
oui alors il avait enlevé les cowboys
c'est vrai oui non c'était la première
police municipale qui a été créée en ile
de france voilà déjà les dents 357
magnum cher mais c'est normal mais ils
sont tous armés c'est pour la sécurité
et on a créé aussi la vidéosurveillance
oui on a été aussi les premiers et
maintenant tout le monde réclame et des
polices municipales
c'est l'avis des oignons d'ailleurs
c'est entendu c'est horrible soyez des
caméras partout il y en a partout ici
j'ai aussi regardé vous avez choisi
balade à levallois au petit fils mais au
moins on n'est pas agressé comme ça je
suis pas sûr que ce soit vraiment le
remède un progrès c'est vous avez
j'habite à gennevilliers à chaque fois
je traversais levallois j'avais peur de
me faire agresser par votre police
municipale ait jamais rien fait moi on
sait jamais là bas en tout cas vous vous
avez été condamné en attendant donc nous
pour l'instant ça va quoi la 5000 pour
plusieurs
[Musique]
valence bien non ce qu'on peut dire
quand même si vous êtes transformé un
peu le valoir une sorte de monaco n'ont
qu'à une espèce de petit endroit comme
ça tu sûr protégé non mais c'est vrai
c'est un c'est une ville où il fait bon
vivre
ouais trois paires sécurité matin j'ai
dû prendre que ça fait deux ans qu'elle
utilise la marche bien alors vous
achetez donc un appartement fin 500 m²
en face de la mairie construite alors
j'ai quitté neuilly pour partir à
levallois mais quand ils ont construit
l'immeuble s'est réservée un duplex de
500 mètres carrés on avait un
appartement à neuilly en est vendu on a
racheté à levallois comme tout le monde
c'est là où travailler donc les fameuses
employés municipaux qui vous aurait été
tellement ils sont choyés municipaux
venait m'aider lorsque j'avais besoin
d'eux voilà là il ya un problème c'est
que le juge halphen fameux juge halphen
s'intéresse aux hlm des hauts-de-seine
et surtout au directeur de l'office des
hlm des hauts-de-seine didier schuller
il a une sombre histoire où le beau père
du juge halphen monsieur maréchal est
mêlé à une tentative de chantage sur
schuller enfin c'est ce que vous en tous
les cas vous accréditer comme thèse vous
dites je ne sais pas lequel des deux
donc entre schuller et halphen risque le
plus la prison écoutez c'est de la très
vieille histoire et histoires faire
c'est une nouvelle preuve qu'elles sont
pas réglés des histoires regardez pas
qu'on y est on sait que c'est une très
vieille histoire est tombé c'est
visiblement une histoire de famille
maréchal et halphen beau père avait le
juge moi je suis jamais rentrer là
dedans
ouais dans tous les cas le juge a été
dans un premier temps dessaisi du
dossier de la scène à cause de cette
affaire maréchal et puis plus tard il a
quand même été lavé de tout soupçon
c'est à dire qu'il ya eu une annulation
de la procédure
voilà tout simplement vous pensez qu'il
y avait vraiment un vrai problème pensez
pas que c'est un montage total ah non
absolument pas ah bon so lu ment pas non
parce que votre amie sous leur lui par
auberge à ce nom je crois qu'il a eu
très peur et la peur vandamme
bah oui tu veux je sais pas où il est
parti c'était si vous savez bien c'était
le directeur de l'office de hlm donc des
hauts-de-seine et lui il est parti aux
bahamas quand il a vu arriver tout ça et
ensuite
quand vous perdez la mairie en 95 vous
êtes condamné lui vous balance quand
même schubert non je ne sais pas j'ai
jamais une nouvelle vous savez
malheureusement il n'est pas revenu ou
malheureusement il est parti il n'aurait
jamais dû partir des noms mais le
heureusement sérieusement non
sérieusement parce que je crois que il
ya vraiment pas grand chose dans l'est
dans les dossiers c'est pas l'affairé
elf
après à vous et les premiers avec votre
femme donc ça s'arrange pas vous séparer
pendant un an
oui mais vous savez dans un couple ça
fait 25 ans qu'on est marié temps en
temps j'ai pris la petite clé et vous
donneront jean patou bass il est en
prison c'est quasiment je suis là
changer de femme sait pas combien de
fois moi j'ai toujours la même
avez-vous j'ai repris la même après
celle qui l'a si bien dit en 90 sièges
est exclu du groupe rpr donc à
l'assemblée nationale en 97 on est
dissous ouais vous savez oui on devait
aller jusqu'à 98 97 ans et demi en
vacances voila voila je me représente
pas vrai et je prends deux années
sabbatiques aux caraïbes au patronat
non juste à côté martin en france à
saint martin wen bien en france à ma
ville français vous savez quitte à
prendre deux années sabbatiques autant
les pandas saint-martin soit ouverte ou
bien entre nous bien à vous retrouver
stéphane collaro carlos la faiblesse et
les gens les gens
c'est les gens qui habitent là-bas la
pêcherie classe là johnny johnny il
vient il a lui aussi la prise six mois
sabbatiques 1 à saint-martin et vous
dirigez une radio dans un endroit qui
s'appelle mariko soit un énorme c'est la
capitale de saint-martin même c'est fou
non
vous avez vraiment l'esprit management
et votre soif et de la décoration
il décore sa maman voilà alors vous
revenez vous revenez aux besoins de huy
sabbatique vous revenez bah oui parce
que vous savez les îles les cocotiers
tout ça c'est très agréable génial quand
on y passe quinze jours c'est très bien
un mois c'est vrai qu'au bout de deux
ans vous faire servir à berck bureaux de
vote
je suis content si bien dire c'est que
lorsque non ce que patrick revient avec
sa femme isabelle bel appartement ayant
été vendus ils sont obligés d habiter
chez leur fille
oui parce que ma fille habite à
levallois quand on est à levallois elle
nous met ses grands chez elle en mai
rationnelle et où elle est célibataire
avant dakar et paris
elle est célibataire je vais même vous
dire et elle vous adore la bande quatre
ans ah oui le mec vos sacs qui à la
terreur alors là si je sais pas
j'ai retrouvé à levallois et face au
maître pierre aime ça soit connu voilà
bien à toi les employés de mairie
j'ai beaucoup pas augmenter d'ailleurs
les employés de mairie parce que quand
je suis parti y en avait on se sent bien
figurez-vous quand je reviens il y en a
14 oui c'est quand même extraordinaire
et moi j'en utilise est que de temps en
temps
alors vous voyez y en a qui les
utilisent pas soit 300 bugs trouvés la
ville dans quel état est sérieux
ben un peu dégradée très honnêtement
c'est pour ça d'ailleurs qui m'ont réélu
c'est par hasard touche pour mettre dans
les mains d'un homme non ils ont des
villes d'oyse ont des trottoirs sales
ils ont une
alors déjà sûrs de faire bizarre
vous savez je vais vous dire ce de
levallois oui à l'aise il m'aime
beaucoup
c'est normal oui il y en a même beaucoup
qui ont voté pour moi bien entendu
monsieur moi alors je suis bien d'accord
avec vous mais voilà moi je suis né un
petit peu je n'ai jamais pris monsieur
quand je passe j'ai peur de votre ville
votre police municipale est effrayante
je vous jure ça c'est pas vu ils ont des
grandes et des dents et una ça c'est
plutôt qu'à ça non je vous jure votre
police avec les gens qui n'ont rien à se
reprocher n'ont jamais peur de la police
monsieur regardez vous pensez que c'est
un bandit et je ne serais pas là sinon
je n'y avais peur en passant de votre
ville qui est le bandit vous fait vous
allez faire rire là mais pas pour le
plein ce que j'ai vraiment fou d'horreur
j'ai ça m'a toujours dégoûté ça de
passer à levallois ça se voit que j'ai
pas la gueule de 20,9 de levallois et à
la police municipale qui dirait que nous
sommes toi veut voir papier tout ça
qu'est ce tu fous là non j'aimerais jure
sur la tête de ma mère que c'est vrai la
police municipale n'arrête jamais
quelqu'un pour lui de bonne gestion
je vous ai d'action et je vous assure
qu'elle n'a pas le droit et si elle vous
arrête pour présenter ses papiers il
faut appeler la police nationale est ce
s te permets de vous le demander quand
même avec des armes à la poche et des
bombes lacrymo même sens même sens un
prix national ça doit être à chicago ou
alors vous avez vu ça dans des films de
série b road à vos caméras de
vidéosurveillance mais je vous jure
c'est vrai monsieur linh et têtue vous
jure vous êtes en train de faire rire
tout levallois et pour être sûr de ne
rien rater de dinars 10 tubes abonnez
vous je m'étais 1 pouces bleus